this is a great opportunity for me for  everyone i mean we're having fun the  cast and crew are amazing the scripts  are really clever and we're working  together really well to get together and  it's so it's so special for all of us to  connect again we take every opportunity  we can to get together we love working  together it was really special seven  years i always say people talk about  their high school years for the rest of  their lives and that's only four years  and we had seven so it's like yeah  that's true you know a lot of people had  seven years of high school  who's the glue that holds everybody  together yeah i like to throw parties i  like to keep people together i like to  connect and so we do it whenever we can